Shh whoa here's a good question for you
what does it feel like well that's not
dating anymore being with someone that's
shorter than you you know what's funny
most of my boyfriend's I want to see 90%
of my boyfriend's I've been shorter than
me I feel like it's like mother nature's
saying like not calm the [ __ ] down
we already have enough tall people cuz
every because there's like Asian girls
that I know they're like their
prerequisite for a man is that they have
to be taller than white and you act like
that's [ __ ] hard like [ __ ] relax
your forefoot trees somebody is gonna
help oh hi Jimmy
all right put your brakes little girl
like it that's like their biggest fears
like I can't have a short guy around me
cause like you're 411 I can [ __ ]
something taller than you you'll be fine
don't worry about this [ __ ] before you
you don't care I know I know I don't
care I think I think um
I do hear when the guy doesn't have
confidence in himself
and that's a turn-off for me like I have
a guy with the big dirt it's a big big
but it looks like a giant dick if what
if the guy was five four part is not
that much shorter than you spent nine
words pretty and when he lacks in height
he does have him with hmm so it kind of
balances it out
five four down could you take somebody
that's short he is the love of so it's
fart but then bar somehow went into a
dryer and he got struck by like five
inches would you do what you still would
you still have been attracted to Barton
as you are now if he was five inches
shorter than he is right now he is five
foot four that is literally like four it
just saw the Jason Chen oh I don't know
because then like I hold his hand his
hands are all cute and smaller than mine
I don't know if I can do that not not to
like knock anyone that's five useless
extra confident he still squats like 500
pounds so like Tim like if I start
dating Tim yeah Tim can I date Tim I
could Bobby date Tim it's like someone
like Tim not Tim I mean I know he's like
in a relationship I'm in over the old
[ __ ] getting awkward I know but
someone like Tim with Tim
characteristics that type of confidence
maybe yeah maybe I can look past the
physical [ __ ] look at Bart he looks a
little Isaac a little rainbow he has the
the cute asian rainbow eyes watch this
autopilot there
what we've been taught by this whole
time thank goodness is you're driving
[ __ ] it does it sucks so you could they
part of you with a lot shirt yeah I
think I could
Wow you know I shadow what I thought you
were I'm not shallow at all what are you
talking about baby stuff ceremony yeah
what are you talking about right now
people are always trying to get us
together what it's just [ __ ] weird
it's because of it was ever since the
Geo vision yeah I think when we kept
saying the same words over and over yeah
but that's only had only happens because
of the amount of time you spend together
yeah so the more time you spend with
somebody the more similar you guys
become so just the worst artists imagine
yeah you're getting my moustache I love
that she keep doing it like there was a
case where I'm not gonna he says a new
thing but he used to always professed
how great he was it says who he [ __ ]
who he was being in order for what nice
and this dude was like he it was his
prowess that that's that's that was his
skill he was yeah he was dick at Ron
like that's how he would talk about
himself right so he hooked up with one
of my friends cousins right and I didn't
know that she hooked up with him and
then we were kicking it together and she
was like yo so I met this guy blah blah
blah blah he goes to this goal which was
high school right and he goes by far the
more sex I've ever had
probably worse then I was like what what
the [ __ ] and I was like what was his
name and it turned out to be him and
there was the guy that talked about him
[ __ ] a lot of girls so psych yeah you
[ __ ] a lot of women but it doesn't
mean that your dick was good yeah
because he's the guy that just gets what
he wants out of houses he doesn't think
about what that other person wants I
dated one he's fixed the dick and [ __ ]
hardened he just says he's done well he
he would always just like you can tell
he he just wanted to get off yeah and
then so I got so sick of it cuz I
already told him you know like hey I'm
not enjoying anything and then I got
really sick of a night like one time I
told him I like looked him in the eyes
get off of me right now but not even
well yeah hold in like eight like you
know you said like you asked your burger
and I well I told him you suck
Wow and he still [ __ ] the way he
wanted to yeah that's weird
well whoever he's with I feel really bad
the theme but he is one to talk glad
about it - I'll see that's what I'm
saying and there has to be a very
insecure thing then yeah he did cheat on
me too he was a terrible how many times
did you get cheated on what the [ __ ]